hi everyone share here's another group
of five puzzles in each position is
white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to puzzle 1 is Queen h6
forcing pawn takes Queen that's the only
response and after rook takes pawn the
King has a couple choices neither one is
good King to h5 is going to run into a
mate and three with rook takes pawn or
King g7 we'll just delay the inevitable
for one additional move Bishop takes
pawn forcing King to g8 or h8 both of
those moves can be met with rook to f8
and that's mate so moving on to the
second puzzle once again White's move
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white ok the
solution to puzzle 2 is rook to h8
forcing King takes rook and now this
King is within striking distance of the
light night after night to f7 we have
this fork going on but not only that we
have the White Queen now in view of the
black Queen as is often the case in
chess unprotected pieces leads to
tactics and that's exactly what we have
here with the black queen after rook
takes Knight Queen takes Queen we just
have white now with a material advantage
and this is going to be enough to confer
to win so that's the solution to puzzle
number 2 let's have a look at the third
one ok once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is Bishop to e5 it's
important to take into account that b2
is under fire well both the bishop and
rook are converging on that pawn and so
Bishop to e5 interrupts that idea and
also opposes a very serious threat to
black we're just know black is excuse me
white is just getting ready to take that
bishop and unfortunately there's no good
defense for example if Queen takes
Bishop we just have ripped to g8 and
that's mate looking at an alternative if
Bishop takes Bishop we once again have
rook g8 one of those deflecting moves
chasing the black queen away from the
defense of the
Bishop after Queen takes rook if Queen
takes bishop and we just have these
blocks that black can do which is just
leading to me if there's maybe one
additional way to maybe put up
resistance in this position in the form
of rook takes on f2 one way of finishing
things up is to just take the bishop and
after black recaptures queen c3 not only
is the rook pinned but it's also
unprotected which is that much more
difficult to get out of usually it's bad
enough if one of your pieces in a pen
this rook is not only in a pen but again
it's also unprotected so after let's say
Queen d8 rook to f4 this rook is going
to be lost and so too is the black King
so that's the solution of the third one
basically the key move to that this
puzzle right here is that Bishop e5 move
moving out to the fourth go ahead pause
video white to play okay the solution to
this one is this quiet move rook to e4
maybe one of the more difficult moves to
have foreseen and it's important to
recognize that this rook cannot be taken
because of the matin - threat which is
to say Knight g6 context tonight rook h4
and that's me so it's important to have
foreseen that and assuming that black
does see that maybe there's another way
to maybe put up resistance by way of
Knight to e7 which is doing one thing
you know actually while it's doing one
thing watching over g6 it's also getting
in the way of this bishops defense of
the F a rook now why is that important
in this position well as a result of
this last move Knight to e7 this rook
now on g8 is overloaded such that it has
two roles has to watch over this f8 rook
and this g7 pond and that's not really a
position you want any of your pieces to
be in really for any amount of time and
in this position what I could do is
implement this tactic of deflection just
capturing the pond deflecting the rook
away from the defense of this f8 rook
and essentially what has just occurred
white is not only up in exchange but
also upon
if there's maybe one other possible
variation if let's say Bishop takes
Knight just removing that possible
Knight check move once again this rook
is still overloaded since the bishop is
no longer on d6 to watch over FA bishop
takes g7 will once again do the trick
basically pick your favorite variation
to win at this point however way you
slice it once again white is up the
exchange let's just say in this
variation white is up the exchange and
upon so I'm moving on to the last puzzle
puzzle number five go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one starts off with Bishop d3
landing a check and after a pawn to g6
maybe one of the more difficult moves to
have foreseen which is to say this rook
to h8 move which is leading to checkmate
if King g7 we just have Queen f8 and
that would be main so trying to delay
mate for as long as possible
King takes rook once again Queen to f8
King h7 Queen takes pawn check King h8
Queen back to f8 King h7 Bishop takes
pawn check and if your king takes bishop
we have this nice finish
Queen to g8 and just this Queen and two
pawns are covering basically all the
runaway points that this black King
could possibly go to this is turning out
to be checkmate
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you're able to take something away
from it and be sure to let me know how
you did by way of a comment thanks bye